From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole, sitting in for Ira Glass. Back when Erin was in high school, she had this friend, Josh. They'd known each other practically since they were born. Their parents were friends. This was in a small, small city in Wisconsin. Fun was going down to this park with buffalo in it and throwing them hunks of bread.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯主持。艾琳上高中的时候，有个朋友叫乔什。他们几乎是从出生就认识了，父母也是朋友。那是威斯康星州一个非常小的城市。他们以前的乐趣就是去公园看野牛，给它们扔面包块。
Anyway, Erin was 15, Josh was a year older. And one particular day--
总之，艾琳15岁，乔什比她大一岁。有一天——
He gave me a mixtape, like a mixed CD-ROM.
他给了我一张混音带，就像是一张混合内容的CD光盘。
Just to say, this was long enough ago that the word "ROM" naturally followed the word "CD." We're talking maybe 2007, 2008.
顺便提一下，那时候“CD”后面自然会跟着“ROM”这个词，还是很久以前的事。我们说的可能是2007年或2008年。
I can see-- I can see the CD-ROM.
我能看见——我能看见那张CD光盘。
You can see it in your mind's eye, you mean. You're not looking at it, right?
你是说在脑海里能浮现出它的样子吧。你现在并不是真的在看着它，对吧？
No, certainly not. I can see, like, Sharpie scribbled all over it in sort of scrawled handwriting and squiggles, is what I can recall.
不，当然不是。我能记得上面有马克笔乱涂乱画的痕迹，还有些潦草的字迹和线条。
Josh was into theater. He and Erin did plays together, actually-- musicals at this little community theater in town.
乔什喜欢戏剧。事实上，他和艾琳一起演过戏——就是在镇上那家小社区剧院里演音乐剧。
He was like, if there was a jock of theatre kids, like, that would be him.
他就像是那种戏剧社里的运动健将，如果真有这种人的话，那肯定就是他。
Hm.
嗯。
So charismatic. You know, like, the star of every play. Really, like, grabbing everything he could out of life. You could say he was a little bit dramatic.
太有魅力了。你知道，就像每部戏的主角。真的，就像他在尽情攫取生活中的一切。你可以说他有点戏剧化。
She only remembers a couple of the songs that were on the mixtape. She does remember the exact number of songs, for reasons that will become clear in a minute. There were 12 of them. 12 songs.
她只记得混音带里的一两首歌。出于一些一会儿就会明朗的原因，她记得歌曲的确切数量。一共12首。12首歌。
I dutifully uploaded it into my iTunes and listened to it, and didn't think much of it. I definitely didn't read into it as I should have. I mean, literally.
我很尽责地把它上传到iTunes并听了，但没多想。我绝对没有像我应该做的那样去解读它。我是说，字面意义上的。
Literally, because of what happened next. Mind you, this next part was months after he gave her the CD-- solidly months.
字面意义上的，因为接下来发生了什么。提醒一下，这接下来的一部分是在他给她CD几个月后——确实是几个月。
Oh, I was, I don't know, poking around in my iTunes library, reorganizing something. And I'm looking at it, and it dawns on me that the song titles spell out, like an acrostic, "I love you, Erin."
哦，我当时，我不知道，在iTunes资料库里随便翻翻，重新整理什么的。我看着它，突然意识到这些歌名拼凑在一起，就像藏头诗一样，写着“我爱你，艾琳”。
Wait a second.
等一下。
Yeah.
是的。
So down the left-hand side of the track listing in iTunes--
所以iTunes曲目列表左侧顺下来——
Mhm.
嗯。
--the first letter of every song as you read downward spelled out "I love you, Erin."
——每一首歌的第一个字母往下读，拼出了“I love you, Erin”。
Yeah, it did.
是的，没错。
Erin had missed it at first because, loading it into iTunes, somehow the track listing had been reversed. So instead of spelling out "I love you, Erin," it said, "Nire ouy evol I." Not quite as romantic.
艾琳起初错过了，因为把它加载到iTunes时，不知怎么曲目列表被颠倒了。所以它没拼出“I love you, Erin”，而是拼成了“Nire ouy evol I”。没那么浪漫了。
The two songs she still remembers? One was "Yellow" by Coldplay. That was the Y in you. The E at the end of love-- or maybe the beginning of Erin-- was "Elephant Love Medley" from the movie Moulin Rouge, which itself works a little like a mixtape. These two characters, Christian and Satine, just hurl lines from famous love songs back and forth at each other.
她还记得的那两首歌？一首是酷玩乐队的《Yellow》。那是“you”里的Y。结尾的E——或者说是艾琳开头的E——是电影《红磨坊》里的《Elephant Love Medley》，这首歌本身就有点像混音带。两个角色，克里斯蒂安和萨婷，只是不停地向对方抛出著名情歌里的歌词。
[MUSIC - "ELEPHANT LOVE MEDLEY" FROM MOULIN ROUGE]
[音乐 - 《红磨坊》中的《Elephant Love Medley》]
(SINGING) I can't survive without your sweet love. Oh, baby, don't leave me this way.
（歌唱）没有你甜蜜的爱，我无法生存。哦，宝贝，别这样离开我。
(SINGING) You'd think that people would have had enough of silly love songs.
（歌唱）你以为人们已经听够了愚蠢的情歌。
Erin got all cringey about that one. And you might think "Elephant Love Medley" alone would be a dead giveaway. But to her, that was just Josh being Josh. Like she said, dramatic. A thing about mixtapes, they're like the emojis of yesteryear. You couldn't always be sure what the intended meaning was, or if the recipient would comprehend said meaning. Like, does he love me, or does he just love these songs? So in that way, Josh literally spelling it out, leaving nothing to the imagination, was a decent strategy. Except even that was lost on Erin due to some dumb hiccup in the machine.
艾琳对那一首感到很尴尬。你可能会觉得单单《Elephant Love Medley》就足以暴露意图了。但对她来说，那只是乔什的一贯作风。就像她说的，戏剧化。混音带这种东西，就像当年的表情符号。你无法确定预期的含义是什么，或者接收者是否能理解这个含义。比如，他是爱我，还是只是爱这些歌？所以从这个角度看，乔什直接拼写出来，不留任何想象空间，倒是个不错的策略。只是因为机器的一个愚蠢故障，连这都被艾琳忽略了。
It was-- you know, it was a lot. It was a lot of emotion, which I felt terrible for missing. Even if you're not going to reciprocate, at least you feel like you should be getting the gesture.
那真是——你知道，分量很重。那是很浓厚的情感，我因为错过而感到非常糟糕。即使你不打算回应，至少你也觉得你应该感受到这份心意。
Right.
对。
But I just hadn't seen it.
但我当时就是没看出来。
He was strictly a friend?
他只是个普通朋友？
He was a friend. We had like, kind of a thing.
他是朋友。我们之间，算是有点什么吧。
You had kind of a thing?
你们算是有点什么？
Yeah. Nurturing a crush. We never dated. But friends for a long time.
是的。暗恋着。我们从未约会过。但做了很长时间的朋友。
May I ask an indelicate question?
我可以问个冒昧的问题吗？
Um, you may.
嗯，可以。
Did you ever kiss or anything?
你们接过吻或者做过什么吗？
Yeah.
有。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I think we probably made out. I mean, I turned out to be gay, so it wasn't my cup of tea.
我想我们大概亲热过。我是说，后来我发现自己是同性恋，所以那不是我的菜。
Right.
明白了。
But-- revelations for the years to come. Just wasn't the time or gender. Who knew?
但是——那是未来的启示。只是时间不对，性别也不对。谁知道呢？
Right. Who knew?
对。谁知道呢？
Yeah.
是的。
Importantly, Erin has no memory of ever telling Josh she saw his secret message. So he was just left in the dark, wondering. They stayed friends, moved on, saw each other a few more times after high school, but eventually lost touch. They haven't spoken in years at this point. It's funny that something that deeply felt was communicated and received, and yet remained unspoken.
重要的是，艾琳完全不记得自己曾告诉过乔什她看到了他的秘密信息。所以他一直被蒙在鼓里，苦苦猜测。他们保持着朋友关系，继续各自的生活，高中毕业后又见了面，但最终失去了联系。到目前为止，他们已经多年没说过话了。有趣的是，那种深刻的情感曾经被传达并被接收，却始终没能说出口。
I always thought of her like Hermione Granger. She was like my Hermione Granger.
我一直把她当作赫敏·格兰杰。她就像我的赫敏·格兰杰。
This, of course, is Josh. I didn't bring up the mixtape right away when I talked to him. First, I just asked him what he remembered about Erin.
这就是乔什。我和他交谈时，没有立刻提起混音带的事。首先，我只是问他关于艾琳的记忆。
She was just so smart and well-respected by everybody, and could just talk circles around anybody. And yeah, her intelligence was very intimidating to me.
她非常聪明，受人尊敬，说话总是逻辑清晰，令人折服。是的，她的才华让我感到非常有压力。
Intimidating, really?
有压力，真的吗？
But in a friendly way. She would never show off about it. I had a crush on her, to be honest. Any time I would happen to drive by her place, I would think, like, the one that got away. You know, that was always like the feeling.
但那种压力是友好的。她从不显摆。老实说，我曾经暗恋过她。每当开车经过她家时，我总会想，她是那个我错失的人。你知道，那种感觉一直都在。
Wow.
哇。
But-- yeah, we were friends.
但是——是的，我们是朋友。
Josh, unfortunately, doesn't have a copy of the mixtape anymore either. Didn't remember any of the songs that were on it. But he did remember spelling out his devotion with the titles. He was bashful about it, as a lot of people would be when talking about stuff they did as a teenager.
遗憾的是，乔什手里也没有那张混音带了。也不记得上面有哪些歌。但他确实记得用歌名拼出了他的深情。他对此感到害羞，就像许多人谈论青少年时期做过的事时那样。
I guess I was reading, like, Dan Brown and all of these kind of spy things, and just, like, throwing hidden messages into things. And yeah, I guess I was trying to do it in my own way.
我想我当时在读丹·布朗之类的间谍小说，喜欢往各种东西里藏隐藏信息。是的，我想我是在用自己的方式尝试这样做。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
And you could practically hear him blushing when I told him that he had put "Elephant Love Medley" on there.
当我告诉他他在上面放了《Elephant Love Medley》时，你几乎能听到他脸红的声音。
[GIGGLING]
[窃笑]
Yep. That's because I thought I was Christian from Moulin Rouge. Yeah. I just loved the kind of level of seriousness he put on romantic love. I always had a thing about that.
没错。那是因为我当时以为自己是《红磨坊》里的克里斯蒂安。是的。我只是喜欢他那种对浪漫爱情的极其认真的态度。我一直对那个很有感觉。
Clearly.
显然如此。
And much to my detriment at times, honestly. And you know, there's a million ways we could psychoanalyze that, but--
有时这对我来说也是种伤害，说实话。你知道，我们可以有一百万种方式来从心理学上分析它，但是——
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Yeah. Did I-- did I tell her that it spelled that? I really hope I didn't.
是的。我有没有——我有告诉过她那上面拼出了什么吗？我真的希望我没说。
No, no, no.
没有，没有。
OK. I hope she found it out on her own.
好的。我希望她是自己发现的。
Well, OK. So here's what happened. Erin brought the CD home.
好吧，好的。事情是这样的。艾琳把CD带回家了。
I took Josh through everything Erin told me. After all these years, he was only just now learning what happened with his little Da Vinci love code. That she had seen it, the message got through. She just hadn't felt the same.
我带乔什梳理了艾琳告诉我的一切。时隔多年，他才刚刚知道他的“达芬奇密码”爱意最终发生了什么。她看到了，信息传达到了。只是她没有同样的感觉。
Wow. OK. Well, I guess I couldn't have asked for it to go any better than that.
哇。好吧。我想我没法要求比这更好的结果了。
Wait. How is that it going well?
等等。这怎么就算好结果了？
Well, because it's a happy accident, you know? It's kind of cool that it happened in its own time.
因为这是一种幸福的意外，你知道吗？这种事情能在它自己的时间里发生，这很酷。
I don't know. I picture a lovelorn Josh sitting in his bedroom, like waiting, like wondering, like, when is she going call me?
我不知道。我脑海里浮现出乔什坐在卧室里，忧心忡忡地等待，心想，她什么时候会给我打电话？
Yeah, I mean, that's true. As I said, I was kind of intimidated by her, you know? And I think, particularly at that time, for Erin to be the person that I would date was, like, beyond something that seemed realistic, I guess.
是的，我是说，那是真的。正如我所说，我对她很有压力，你知道吗？我觉得，特别是在那个时候，艾琳能成为我约会的对象，超出了现实感，我想。
Oh, you thought she was out of your league.
哦，你觉得她高不可攀。
Totally.
完全是这样。
Oh, I see.
哦，我明白了。
I wanted her to know somehow on some level, but I also didn't want to push the matter or make her, you know, feel uncomfortable, or-- I don't know. I always thought she'd probably turn me down.
我希望能让她在某种程度上知道，但又不想强求，或者让她感到不自在，或者——我不知道。我总觉得她很可能会拒绝我。
I guess I just wonder-- I mean, other than it being a sort of very opaque and, one could argue, ineffective way of conveying one's love, to put it in an acrostic on a mixtape--
我只是好奇——我是说，除了把爱意藏在混音带的藏头诗里这种非常晦涩且可以说效率低下的表达方式之外——
I don't think it was ineffective. I challenge that. I think it's like-- it's not even about if it got through, in terms of a really, really clear communication. It's like, if it was there, even if it was out of order, you know, when she first popped it in, it was somehow there, I think, in my mind-- like energetically, you know? And I still see the transmission, even if it was kind of quiet, you know?
我不觉得那是低效的。我质疑这一点。我觉得——甚至不在于它是否被传达得非常非常清晰。就像，如果它在那里，即使是乱序的，你知道，当她第一次放进去的时候，它不知怎么地就在那里了，我想——在某种能量层面，你知道吗？我仍然能看到那个传输，即使它很安静，你知道吗？
I don't want to sound too grand, but I think that right there is the power of mixtapes when you put them together a certain way-- the power of music, even. Or at least the power that we believe it has. That it can confess devotion on our behalf, even in the form of an exploded puzzle. Even the most casual mixtape-- or playlist these days-- that you make for a friend, you're saying, this is what I like. Or a lot of times, this is what I'm feeling right now. In a way, you're saying, this is who I am.
我不想说得太宏大，但我认为这就是混音带在你用心制作时的力量——甚至是音乐的力量。或者至少是我们相信它拥有的力量。它能代表我们表白，即便是在碎片拼图的形式下。哪怕是最随意的混音带——或者现在的播放列表——你为朋友制作时，你其实在说，这些是我喜欢的。或者很多时候，这些是我此刻的感受。在某种程度上，你在说，这就是我。
Songs gathered together like that are a kind of parlance, a language. The words are someone else's, but they're also our own. So that's what's coming up on today's episode, kind of a mixtape of its own, because we have a crush on you, and because the particular songs in this show tell you a surprising amount about the people listening to them. We can't wait to play them for you. Stay with us.
像这样收集在一起的歌曲是一种交流方式，一种语言。歌词是别人的，但它们也是我们自己的。这就是今天这一集的内容，本身就像是一张混音带，因为我们对你们心怀好感，也因为节目中的特定歌曲向你们传达了关于听众本身惊人的信息。我们迫不及待地想播放给你们听。请继续收听。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Track One, Just Be Good To Me.
第一首，《Just Be Good To Me》。
So you use music to connect with other people or send a message a la mix tape, but there are all of these other times, of course, when you sort of communicate with yourself through music. Putting on a song to revel in some feeling, or feeling like this or that band or singer is speaking directly to you. This next collection of songs works like that. They're all of a piece in a way that writer Nichole Perkins really related to. Here's Nichole.
所以，你用音乐与他人建立联系或传达信息，就像混音带一样，但当然，还有许多其他时候，你通过音乐与自己对话。播放一首歌来沉浸在某种感觉中，或者感觉某个乐队或歌手在直接对你诉说。接下来的这一组歌曲就是这样的。它们以一种作家尼科尔·珀金斯深有同感的方式自成一体。请听尼科尔带来的内容。
There have always been songs about cheating spouses and their lovers. When women sing them, they tend to be from the point of view of the disappointed and hurt wife. In Dolly Parton's unforgettable "Jolene," she begs a woman not to take her man. In Shirley Brown's bluesy, confrontational "Woman to Woman," Shirley lets the other woman know she's not letting her ruin her happy home. But how happy can your home be if you have to call another woman and tell her it's happy?
关于出轨配偶及其情人的歌总是层出不穷。当女性演唱这些歌曲时，她们往往是从那个失望和受伤的妻子的角度出发。在多莉·帕顿令人难忘的《Jolene》中，她恳求另一个女人不要抢走她的男人。在雪莉·布朗忧郁而具有对抗性的《Woman to Woman》中，雪莉让那个女人知道她不会让对方破坏自己的幸福家庭。但如果你必须给另一个女人打电话说你家庭幸福，那么你的家庭能有多幸福呢？
Songs like these make the other woman a Villain with a capital V. Those songs weren't for me. I was more interested in "auntie songs," the songs from the point of view of the other woman. They were what women in the wrong corner of love triangles sang about finding good love in the middle of bad decisions. They were old-school soul and R&B hits that our mothers, aunties, and older play cousins used to listen to with shining eyes and far away expressions, holding sweating glasses of drinks that were off limits to us kids. We were too young to be singing those songs, but we felt their power anyway.
这类歌曲把第三者塑造成了“反派”。这些歌不适合我。我更感兴趣的是“阿姨之歌”，即从第三者视角出发的歌。它们是身陷爱情三角关系泥潭的女性，关于在糟糕的决策中寻找真爱的歌。那是老派灵魂乐和R&B金曲，我们的母亲、阿姨和年长的表姐妹们曾经眼中闪烁着泪光，目光迷离地听着，手里拿着我们小孩子不能碰的含酒精饮料。我们太年轻，不懂得唱这些歌，但我们依然感受到了它们的力量。
We heard the longing in the singer's vocal acrobatics, and it moved us, even if we weren't sure why. We'd hear them on the radio, played during every quiet storm, sometimes with dedications, like "From Denise to that special someone. She says you know who you are." And then the ultimate side chick anthem, "As We Lay," by Shirley Murdock, would begin to play, a song about everything that happens in the moments before your man has to go home to his wife.
我们在歌手的嗓音技巧中听到了那种渴望，它打动了我们，即使我们不确定原因。我们会在收音机里听到它们，在每个深夜广播中播放，有时还伴有留言，比如“这是丹妮丝点给那位特别的人的，她说你知道你是谁。”然后，终极第三者赞歌，雪莉·默多克的《As We Lay》就会开始播放，那是一首讲述在你的男人必须回家陪他妻子之前的那些时刻里发生的一切的歌。
[MUSIC - "AS WE LAY" BY SHIRLEY MURDOCK]
[音乐 - 雪莉·默多克的《As We Lay》]
(SINGING) Morning, and we slept the night away.
（歌唱）清晨，我们共度了一晚。
Auntie songs are where we got to hear from the other woman and realize maybe she's actually a human being with emotions too. We're hearing the perspectives of women who know their love is futile, but they'll take what they can get for as long as they can get it.
“阿姨之歌”是我们得以倾听第三者心声的地方，让我们意识到也许她也是一个有感情的人。我们听到的是那些明知爱情徒劳无功，却甘愿在有限时间内尽可能获取一切的女性的视角。
(SINGING) We both belong to someone else as we slept the night away.
（歌唱）我们俩都属于别人，而我们共度了一晚。
One of the most famous auntie songs is an undercover one that most people don't realize is from the perspective of the other woman. In "Saving All My Love For You," Whitney Houston calls out her lover's lies, even as she continues to wait for him. "You used to tell me we'd run away together. Love gives you the right to be free. You said be patient. Just wait a little longer. But that's just an old fantasy."
最著名的“阿姨之歌”之一是一首隐晦的作品，大多数人并没意识到它是从第三者的视角出发的。在《Saving All My Love For You》中，惠特尼·休斯顿指责了她情人的谎言，即便她仍在等待他。“你曾告诉我我们会远走高飞。爱给你自由的权利。你说要耐心。再等一会儿。但那只是一个古老的幻想。”
[MUSIC - "SAVING ALL MY LOVE FOR YOU" BY WHITNEY HOUSTON]
[音乐 - 惠特尼·休斯顿的《Saving All My Love For You》]
When Whitney hits that beautiful extended high note on "fantasy," it feels like we're all falling back into an ocean of her lover's lies with her. And like her, we let ourselves be carried away anyway.
当惠特尼在唱“fantasy”（幻想）这个词时，高音拉得如此优美，感觉我们所有人都随着她坠入了她情人的谎言之海中。就像她一样，我们还是让自己沉溺其中了。
(SINGING) But that's just an old fantasy.
（歌唱）但那只是一个古老的幻想。
When I was 25 years old and living in New Orleans, I met a man with a voice made for night. He was a lovely, nerdy thing with a shaved head and freckles, a sprinkle of joy across his nose and cheeks, and a few dots on his lips that were clearly targets for my affection. He wasn't yet 30, but he already had the look of a hip-hop professor in line at Whole Foods. I'll call him Bayard.
当我25岁住在新奥尔良时，我遇到了一个嗓音天生适合夜晚的男人。他是个可爱、有些书呆子气的家伙，剃着光头，长着雀斑，鼻梁和脸颊上洒满了欢乐，嘴唇上还有几颗痣，那显然是我钟情的坐标。他还没到30岁，但排队买全食超市时，就已经有了嘻哈教授的气质。我叫他巴亚德。
At dinner with him and a friend, I laughed too often and too hard at something Bayard said. He slipped me a questioning glance after one giggle too many, and I tried to pull myself together. But it was too late. At a club later, we ended up sitting next to each other, trying to talk over the music. At midnight, we sat in my car, talking. And then the sun reminded us our deodorants had been working for 24 hours.
和他以及一个朋友共进晚餐时，他说的某个笑话让我笑得太频繁且太用力了。笑得太过火后，他投给我一个质疑的眼神，我试图让自己镇定下来。但为时已晚。后来在夜店里，我们坐在了一起，试图在音乐声中交谈。午夜时分，我们坐在车里聊天。直到太阳提醒我们，我们的除臭剂已经坚持了24小时。
I decided to shoot my shot. Is there anyone back home waiting for your morning call, I asked him. He took a long time to answer, which was answer enough. Yeah, there is, he finally said. He looked down at his hands, and I looked at them too. Of course he was involved with someone. He was smart, cute, and funny, and I'd met him at the wrong time.
我决定主动出击。我问他，家里有没有人在等你的晨间电话？他思考了很久才回答，而这本身就是答案。他终于说，是的，有。他低头看着自己的手，我也看着。他果然是有伴侣的。他聪明、可爱、有趣，我却在错误的时间遇到了他。
We exchanged email addresses because that felt safe. There was nothing wrong with having a pen pal, was there? Soon, we were exchanging pages of text almost daily. He'd call me at work and have me crying from laughter. And sometimes, he'd call me at night when that someone back home was out with her girls, and he'd talk to me with that voice saying what his words wouldn't.
我们交换了电子邮件地址，因为那感觉很安全。有个笔友总没错吧？很快，我们几乎每天都在交换长篇邮件。他会在工作时打电话给我，逗得我开怀大笑。有时，他会在夜晚那个家里的人跟姐妹们出去时打电话给我，用那种嗓音对我诉说着他言语无法表达的情感。
After about three months of constant communication, he came back to New Orleans for another visit. I don't know what he told that someone back home, but he told me he loved me. I said it back to him. We kissed. My memory tells me I had candles lit, and that's probably true. I do love candles. I remember his face as he looked at me and told me I was beautiful. I believed him.
在持续联系了大约三个月后，他再次来到新奥尔良探访。我不知道他对他家里那位说了什么，但他告诉我说他爱我。我也回应了他。我们接吻了。记忆中我点上了蜡烛，那很可能是真的。我确实喜欢蜡烛。我记得他看着我、告诉我我很美时的神情。我相信了他。
He was engaged to be married, and for the most part, I didn't care. I definitely had some woman-to-woman guilt, since I'd had my own heartbreaking experiences with cheating exes. But Bayard and I started seeing each other when I was firmly in what we'd now call my "hot girl summer" phase. I also knew I wasn't the first woman he cheated on her with. I decided I couldn't care more about his woman than he did. I refused to take responsibility for his decisions, but I had no problem benefiting from them.
他已经订婚了，大体上，我不在乎。我确实有过一点“女人对女人”的愧疚感，因为我自己也有过被出轨的伤心经历。但巴亚德和我开始往来时，我正处于现在所谓的“火辣女孩夏天”阶段。我也知道我不是他背叛妻子的第一个女人。我决定，我不能比他更在乎他的女人。我拒绝为他的决定负责，但我毫不介意从中获益。
Those auntie songs I had swayed along with because I appreciated a talented voice and good music appealed differently to me during this time. Now they were pep talks. In "Secret Lovers," by Atlantic Starr, a pair of lovers are both devoted to other people, yet unable to stop their attraction. I didn't have anyone I was committed to, but there was a particular verse I kept going back to while I fancied myself in love with Bayard.
那些我曾经因为欣赏好嗓音和好音乐而跟着摆动的“阿姨之歌”，在这段时间对我有了不同的意义。现在它们成了我的打气歌。在亚特兰蒂斯之星乐队的《Secret Lovers》中，一对恋人都忠于别人，却无法停止彼此的吸引。我没有固定的对象，但有一句歌词，在我自以为爱上巴亚德的时候，总是反复想起。
[MUSIC - "SECRET LOVERS" BY ATLANTIC STARR]
[音乐 - 亚特兰蒂斯之星乐队的《Secret Lovers》]
"Sitting at home, I do nothing all day but think about you and hope that you're OK, hoping you'll call before anyone gets home. I wait anxiously alone by the phone." This is the stuff of schoolgirl crushes, of clumsy rom-com heroines, of swooning damsels everywhere. And that's how I felt about Bayard. It just so happened he was committed to someone else.
“坐在家里，我整天什么都不做，只想你，希望你一切安好，希望你在别人回家前给我打个电话。我焦虑地独自守在电话旁。”这是少女暗恋、笨拙的浪漫喜剧女主角以及到处都是神魂颠倒的淑女才有的戏码。而这就是我对巴亚德的感觉。只是碰巧，他已经有了别人。
(SINGING) Secret lovers, that's what we are. Tried so hard to hide the way we feel.
（歌唱）秘密恋人，这就是我们。竭尽全力隐藏我们的感受。
A few weeks after that candlelit visit, I was unexpectedly hospitalized and Bayard was there for me. He called my mother, cleaned up my apartment, and made sure my cat had a fresh litter box. He stayed with me the entire week, even after my family arrived. The care he showed me was a fantasy I'd never allowed myself to indulge.
在那次烛光之夜几周后，我意外住院了，巴亚德陪着我。他给我母亲打电话，打扫了我的公寓，确保我的猫有个干净的猫砂盆。他陪了我整整一周，即使在我家人到达后也是如此。他给予我的关怀是我从未敢沉溺其中的幻想。
He was married a few months later. He emailed me from the honeymoon. And several months after that, we made plans to spend a weekend at a hotel together. He left the hotel website up on his laptop, and his wife found a book I had inscribed with something sneaky. She eventually reached out to me via email and AIM, instant messaging of old. The exact messages have been lost to time and anger, but the gist remains.
几个月后他结婚了。他在蜜月中给我发了邮件。在那之后又过了几个月，我们计划一起在一家酒店过周末。他把酒店网站留在了笔记本电脑上，他的妻子发现了一本我题过词的书，上面写着些鬼鬼祟祟的话。她最终通过电子邮件和老式的AIM即时通讯联系了我。确切的信息早已消失在时间和愤怒中，但大意留存了下来。
What did he tell you about me? He didn't talk much about you. Why you? You'd have to ask him. Why did you do it? I wanted to. Do you love him? I think so, yes. Do you want him? No. I'm not trying to take him from you. I saw your pictures. OK. Does he love you? Ask him. Why did he do it? Ask him.
他跟你说了我什么？他没怎么提过你。为什么是你？你得去问他。你为什么要这样做？我想要这样做。你爱他吗？我想是的，是的。你想要他吗？不。我没想把你抢走。我看了你的照片。好的。他爱你吗？问他。他为什么这么做？问他。
I ping-ponged between a strange loyalty to him, the need to defend myself, the desire to protect her, and the need to be catty. I wanted to tell her to leave, that he cheated before, that if it hadn't been me, it would have been someone else. Bayard's wife reminded me of the petty girls in school who couldn't understand why guys would be interested in me. I didn't have the things I was supposed to in order to be attractive.
我在对他奇怪的忠诚、为自己辩护的需要、保护她的愿望以及刻薄的冲动之间来回摆动。我想让她离开，告诉她他以前就出轨过，如果不是我，也会是别人。巴亚德的妻子让我想起了学校里那些总是无法理解为什么男生会对我有兴趣的琐碎女孩。我并没有所谓的吸引力所需的特质。
I got in a few stingers, but I let her have her shots, whatever she needed to feel better. In giving myself what I wanted, I'd hurt another woman. I felt guilty, even as I would not allow myself to feel ashamed. When I wanted to brush away any concerns about how he was treating his wife, or when I'd start to feel bad about not having a man of my own, I'd put on the SOS Band's "Just Be Good To Me" to gas myself up and keep me focused on myself.
我回击了几下，但也任由她发泄，无论她需要什么来让自己感觉好些。在获得自己想要的东西时，我伤害了另一个女人。我感到内疚，即便我从不让自己感到羞耻。当我想要拂去关于他如何对待他妻子的顾虑，或者当我开始为没有自己的男人而感到难过时，我会播放SOS乐队的《Just Be Good To Me》，来为自己打气，让我专注于自己。
[MUSIC - "JUST BE GOOD TO ME" BY SOS BAND]
[音乐 - SOS乐队的《Just Be Good To Me》]
"I don't care about your other girls, just be good to me." His wife didn't understand how I could be with him and claim to love him, but not want to take him from her. I was no fool. I firmly believe in the adage, "How you got him is how you get got."
“我不在乎你的其他女孩，只要对我好就行。”他的妻子不明白我怎么能和他在一起并声称爱他，却不想从她手中把他抢走。我不是傻瓜。我坚信那句格言：“你怎么得到他的，你就会怎么失去他。”
(SINGING) I don't care about your other girls. Just be good to me. Oooh.
（歌唱）我不在乎你的其他女孩。只要对我好就行。喔。
I think I stopped loving him first. He was the only man I was saying "I love you" to in a romantic sense, but he couldn't say the same, so I stopped answering his emails and calls. He wrote me a letter and I burned it, unopened.
我想我是先停止爱他的。在浪漫意义上，他是唯一一个我对他说“我爱你”的男人，但他无法同样回应，所以我停止回复他的邮件和电话。他给我写了一封信，我没拆开就烧掉了。
After I made the decision to let my relationship with Bayard go, I found myself holding a sweating glass and staring at a blank wall. The auntie songs once gave me strength, and now they gave me permission to cry. I missed someone who was never mine, even though I had made a good decision in moving on from the affair, a decision that had been mine.
在决定结束与巴亚德的关系后，我发现自己拿着含着水珠的玻璃杯盯着一面空白的墙。曾经赋予我力量的“阿姨之歌”，现在给了我流泪的许可。我怀念那个从不属于我的人，尽管在结束这段婚外情时我做出了一个正确的决定，一个属于我自己的决定。
In most auntie songs, we hear the other woman passively waiting for the man to make time for her. But in "Everything I Miss At Home," the singer Cherrelle tells the story of a woman who initiates her infidelity and lets us know she is the one dissatisfied in her main relationship. She cheats without regrets and is grateful to have found someone who gives her everything she's not getting at home. She was not the object of desire, she was in control of it. The song is a groovy slow jam made for a two-step and eye contact, perfect for a woman who refuses to feel remorseful about receiving love from unexpected places.
在大多数“阿姨之歌”中，我们听到第三者被动地等待男人留出时间给她。但在《Everything I Miss At Home》中，歌手谢丽尔讲述了一个主动开始出轨的女性的故事，她让我们知道她才是对原配关系不满的人。她毫无悔意地出轨，并庆幸找到了一个能给予她在家中所得不到的一切的人。她不再是欲望的对象，而是欲望的掌控者。这首歌是一首适合共舞和眼神交流的律动慢歌，非常适合那些拒绝为从意想不到的地方获得爱而感到内疚的女性。
[MUSIC - "EVERYTHING I MISS AT HOME" BY CHERRELLE]
[音乐 - 谢丽尔的《Everything I Miss At Home》]
(SINGING) You give me attention. You're someone who understands my needs.
（歌唱）你给予我关注。你是个懂我需求的人。
I let these songs guide me through an affair, but they didn't tell me what happened after I'd moved on. I started reading romance novels when I was very young and became addicted to the promise of happily ever after. Forever was found in fiction and fairy tales. But in auntie songs, forever was a stolen night.
我让这些歌指引我经历了一段婚外情，但它们没告诉我当我走出来后会发生什么。我很小的时候就开始读浪漫小说，并迷上了“从此幸福快乐”的承诺。永远是在虚构和童话中被找到的。但在“阿姨之歌”中，永远是一段偷来的夜晚。
Does the other woman get her happy ending? Maybe it's enough to stay in a loop of borrowed time. I still haven't figured that out yet. But I know I can be loved any way I want.
第三者能得到她的幸福结局吗？也许停留在借来的时间循环里就足够了。我还没弄清楚这一点。但我知道我可以用我想要的任何方式被爱。
(SINGING) I was just out on the town in search of some fun. I wasn't looking for love.
（歌唱）我只是在镇上寻找一些乐趣。我并没在寻找爱情。
Nichole Perkins is a writer from Nashville, Tennessee. Her memoir, from which this essay is adapted, is called Sometimes I Trip On How Happy We Could Be, and it's out now.
尼科尔·珀金斯是来自田纳西州纳什维尔的作家。本文改编自她的回忆录，书名为《有时我会纠结于我们能有多幸福》，现已出版。
Coming up, they say a little knowledge is a dangerous thing, but it can also make you a beloved rock critic, at least in one case. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，人们常说一知半解是危险的，但它也能让你成为一位受人爱戴的乐评人，至少在一个案例中是这样。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续，我们节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole. Since Ira's was away this week, we made you a mixtape. It's called "This is Just Some Songs." And it's just some songs. Don't get excited.
这是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔。既然艾拉这周不在，我们就为你制作了一张混音带。它叫《这只是一些歌》。它就只是一些歌。别太兴奋。
We're at Track Two, Music is Easy. It struck me that most of the songs in the show today are from a long time ago, and I wanted to play you like a minute of this one tune. It's a little newer. It's from early last year. And for me, it's just one of those earworms that I'm, like, delighted to have in my ear all the time. The artist calls themselves Josephine Network, a self-described "shapeshifting yenta" in drag. It's a song about unburdening yourself, getting whatever it is off your chest through music.
我们来到了第二首，《Music is Easy》。我突然想到，今天节目里的大部分歌曲都是很久以前的，我想让你听大约一分钟这首曲子。它稍微新一点。是去年年初的。对我来说，它是那种我很高兴能一直萦绕在耳边的“洗脑歌”。这位艺术家称自己为Josephine Network，自称是变装界的“变色龙媒婆”。这是一首关于卸下负担，通过音乐抒发心中郁闷的歌。
[MUSIC - "MUSIC IS EASY" BY JOSEPHINE NETWORK]
[音乐 - Josephine Network的《Music is Easy》]
Music is easy, it's a laugh. Play with a melody, make it last. People are crazy. They change every day. What price would you pay to get your way? Oh, music is easy. Sing what you dream. What would you feel? Say what you mean, oh. Some make you happy. Some leave you scarred. Living is hard. So play your guitar. Oh.
音乐很简单，只是一场笑话。玩弄旋律，让它永恒。人们很疯狂。他们每天都在变。为了达成目的你愿意付出什么代价？哦，音乐很简单。唱出你梦想的。你会有什么感觉？说出你的意思，哦。有些让你快乐。有些留下伤痕。生活很难。所以弹奏你的吉他。哦。
Isn't that something? I also wanted to play that for you because where they say "say what you mean," this next track on our mix tape is about saying explicitly, indisputably, what you mean with music-- although, the people in the story might argue that it is not always easy. Part of their job is hunting for exactly the right song for the occasion.
是不是很特别？我想为你播放这首歌还有一个原因，因为当他们唱到“说出你的意思”时，我们混音带里的下一首曲子就是关于用音乐明确、无可争议地表达你的意思——尽管故事中的人们可能会说这并不总是那么容易。他们的部分工作是寻找最适合场合的歌曲。
So this is Track Three, The End of the Road. And I think the only other thing you need to know is that my colleague, Chana Joffe Walt, is a big fan of those slideshows that schools put together at the end of the year for graduations and that kind of thing. Retrospective slideshows. Loves them. Here's Chana.
所以这是第三首，《The End of the Road》。我想你唯一还需要知道的是，我的同事查娜·乔夫·沃尔特非常喜欢学校在毕业季末尾制作的那种幻灯片，诸如此类的东西。回顾性幻灯片。非常喜欢。请听查娜的报道。
I got a bonus end of the year slideshow last spring. I wasn't expecting it because it was for my second grader, and he wasn't graduating anything. Still, I was pleased when his teacher wrote the class to say she wanted to mark the end of the year, we should all join their morning meeting by Zoom, and there was going to be a slideshow.
去年春天，我意外得到了一份学年末的幻灯片惊喜。我没期待它，因为那是为了我的二年级学生制作的，他并没有要毕业。尽管如此，当他的老师写信给班级说她想纪念学年结束，我们都应该加入他们的Zoom晨会，并且会有一个幻灯片时，我还是很高兴。
Like Sean said, I do love slideshows, and not in a normal way, I don't think. I always cry, every time. And I'm really not a crier, but these stupid slideshows always work on me. I will cry when it's not my own child graduating. I will cry even if I don't know a single kid in the slideshow. For instance, here, I was at an elementary school that my kids do not go to. I was there reporting.
就像肖恩说的，我确实喜欢幻灯片，而且方式有点不寻常。我总是哭，每一次。我真的不是那种爱哭的人，但这些愚蠢的幻灯片总是对我起作用。即便是别人家的孩子毕业，我也会哭。即使我一个都不认识，我也会哭。例如，在这里，我是在一所我的孩子没上过的学校。我在报道。
It wouldn't be a graduation without a slideshow. Enjoy.
没有幻灯片的毕业典礼是不完整的。请欣赏。
And it takes 10 seconds. The pictures of the kids at work at their tables, out on their field trips in matching t-shirts. I love when they do the photos from the beginning of the year and then the end, and you see the kids get teeth and long legs. In the front row, there's a grandpa wiping his eyes. I was done.
只需要10秒钟。孩子们在桌边工作的照片，穿着配套T恤参加实地考察的照片。我喜欢他们把年初和年末的照片放在一起，你会看到孩子们长出了牙齿，有了大长腿。在前排，有位爷爷在擦眼泪。我彻底沦陷了。
One more, and I promise I'll get to the point here in a second. This one was the most embarrassing one for me. I went to this graduation at a different school I was reporting on. Oh, my god.
还有一个，我保证一会儿就说到点子上。这一次对我来说最尴尬。我去参加了另一所学校的毕业典礼，我在做报道。哦，我的天。
Now we'll have the rose ceremony.
现在我们要举行玫瑰仪式。
Do you guys know about this diabolical thing they now do at some high school graduations, where they give each kid a rose?
你们知道现在一些高中毕业典礼上做的这件邪恶的事情吗，他们给每个孩子一朵玫瑰？
Each graduate will present a rose to one person who helped them on this journey.
每位毕业生将向在这一旅程中帮助过他们的一人赠送一朵玫瑰。
And then they asked them to bring it to someone in the audience who got them to this moment. Then you see all these kids stumbling over their robes trying to find their mom in the audience, and you see mothers just absorb their daughters in hugs, both of them sobbing.
然后他们要求他们把它带给观众席中促使他们走到这一步的那个人。然后你会看到所有的孩子穿着长袍跌跌撞撞地寻找观众席中的妈妈，你看到母亲们把女儿拥入怀中，两人都啜泣着。
I watched this one awkward 17-year-old boy walk up to his grandma, shove the rose toward her, and mumble "Thank you." And she grabbed him by the neck and pulled him in. Brutal. The woman from the main office in the school, she saw me and came over to pat my arm to tell me it would be OK. Remember, I was not related to a single person graduating in this ceremony.
我看着这个尴尬的17岁男孩走到奶奶面前，把玫瑰塞给她，嘟囔着“谢谢”。她一把抓住他的脖子把他拉进怀里。残暴。学校办公室的那位女士看见了我，走过来拍拍我的手臂说会没事的。记住，典礼上的任何一位毕业生都和我没关系。
Anyway, this year, I joined my child's class by Zoom, and I knew what to expect. We all watched a very sweet slideshow the teacher put together, and I felt nothing. Nothing. We saw pictures of the kids reading in beanbag chairs, learning math, nothing. Making volcanoes, nope. I just felt sort of numb. My attention drifted, I looked at my phone, I looked at everyone in the boxes on Zoom.
总之，今年，我通过Zoom参加了孩子的班级会议，我知道该期待什么。我们都看了老师制作的一个非常甜蜜的幻灯片，但我什么都没感觉到。什么都没有。我们看了孩子们在懒人沙发上阅读、学习数学的照片，什么都没有。制作火山，没有。我只是感到麻木。我的注意力分散了，我看手机，看Zoom方框里的每个人。
And a bunch of slides in, a kid on Zoom unmuted himself to say something random, like my dog smells. And just hearing the sound, I realized, oh, there's no music. That's what's weird about this. There's no song.
幻灯片播放到一半时，一个在Zoom上的孩子取消静音，说了一些随机的话，比如我的狗很臭。听到这个声音，我意识到，哦，没有音乐。这就是奇怪的地方。没有歌。
There was no music in her slideshow? Oh no. That's unacceptable. I've never heard of that before.
她的幻灯片里没有音乐？哦，不。那是不可接受的。我以前从没听说过。
Bess Massey is a school social worker, the maker of many slideshows and the most enthusiastic fan of them too when she's in the audience. Bess cheers for every person in the slideshow, every activity. She cheers for the days of the week.
贝丝·梅西是一位学校社会工作者，她是许多幻灯片的制作人，也是她在观众席时最狂热的粉丝。贝丝为幻灯片里的每个人、每项活动欢呼。她为一周中的每一天欢呼。
That's definitely why you didn't cry. 100%.
那绝对是你没哭的原因。百分之百。
You think that's why I didn't cry? Yeah, I think it is why I didn't cry.
你觉得那就是我没哭的原因？是的，我想那确实是我没哭的原因。
Yes, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
I did talk to the teacher in my son's class. She says she just forgot to put music in. I called Bess, and I also called my friend Rachel Lissy. Rachel and Bess combined have probably put together dozens of slideshows over decades of working at summer camps, running after school programs, and graduations. I asked them both, what does it mean that I didn't feel anything without the music? Here's Rachel.
我确实和儿子班级的老师谈过。她说她只是忘了放音乐。我打电话给贝丝，也打电话给我的朋友雷切尔·利西。雷切尔和贝丝加起来在夏令营、课后项目和毕业典礼工作了几十年，可能制作了几十个幻灯片。我问她们俩，我听不到音乐就毫无感觉意味着什么？请听雷切尔的回答。
Yeah, I don't-- I can't-- I mean, without music-- first of all, like I feel like even though, at this point, we wouldn't be having slideshows actually using, like, slides in, like, an old rotary, I still feel like if you're doing it without music, you can't help but hear, like, a clicking sound. Like, just this, like, sound of just emptiness.
是的，我不知道——我不能——我是说，没有音乐——首先，我觉得即使在此时此刻，我们实际上不会使用像旧转盘那种幻灯片，但我仍然觉得如果你在没有音乐的情况下做，你忍不住会听到那种点击声。就像，这种，空虚的声音。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
No, that's exactly what this slideshow felt like. Yeah, it felt like time was moving so slowly, and the pictures didn't have any of their meaning, or at least not the meaning that I wanted.
不，那正是这个幻灯片给人的感觉。是的，它感觉时间过得很慢，照片没有任何意义，或者至少不是我想要的意义。
Yeah, it's interesting because it's like, there is a way in which the slideshows are celebrating the growth, like the passage of time, like we're a year older. But with music, that feels like wondrous and full of possibility. And without music, it feels just like the clicking of us all towards--
是的，这很有趣，因为它就像，有一种方式让幻灯片在庆祝成长，就像时光流逝，我们大了一岁。但有了音乐，那感觉既奇妙又充满了可能性。没有音乐，它感觉就像我们所有人都在朝着——
Just aging.
只是变老。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Yes, totally. Exactly. Like, I've aged in this slideshow, and I've watched aging, and I feel connected to my own fragile mortality. Thank you, slideshow.
是的，完全正确。就像，我在这个幻灯片里变老了，我目睹了衰老，我感觉与自己脆弱的死亡率相连。谢谢你，幻灯片。
The right song, it can tell your mind what to think about when you look at a bunch of pictures. Of all the possible things you could be thinking about and feeling, the music tells you, no, no, no, this is the one to pick.
合适的音乐，当你看着一堆照片时，它可以告诉你的大脑去想什么。在所有你可能正在思考和感受的事情中，音乐告诉你，不，不，不，这才是要选的那个。
That said, imagine the rose ceremony without music. It'd just be awkward, like watching a bunch of people stumble over chairs, trying to find their seats. So I thought I'd try. Play the same slideshow, but just put a song under it. See if I felt the right things.
话虽如此，想象一下没有音乐的玫瑰仪式。那只会很尴尬，就像看着一群人跌跌撞撞地穿过椅子，试图找到座位。所以我决定尝试一下。播放同样的幻灯片，但在下面放一首歌。看看我是否能感觉到对的感觉。
I was skeptical, though, because this slideshow had a lot of other things getting in the way. For one, we weren't all together watching it in a crowded auditorium. And honestly, mostly what I saw was not the pictures of the kids being cute. I just noticed their masks, and the fact that their desks had plastic partitions. And in some pictures, they're wearing winter coats indoors because they have to have the windows open for ventilation. It just felt dystopian. And I could not really imagine a slideshow on Zoom overcoming all that.
不过我持怀疑态度，因为这个幻灯片还有很多其他妨碍的东西。一方面，我们没有大家挤在一起在礼堂里看。老实说，我看到的主要是孩子们可爱的照片。我只是注意到了他们的口罩，以及他们的课桌有塑料隔板的事实。在一些照片里，他们在室内穿着冬天的外套，因为为了通风他们必须打开窗户。它感觉就像反乌托邦。我真的无法想象Zoom上的幻灯片能克服这一切。
No, no, I think it can work.
不，不，我想它是可以奏效的。
Bess, ever faithful in the medium, believed this was absolutely fixable. She and Rachel both gave me lots of suggestions of songs they thought could work, that I could play during the slideshow to feel the right things. It's not complicated. Bess says basically any song everyone knows can do the job. Pop songs, high energy songs, those are the best.
贝丝，对这种媒介始终如一，相信这绝对是可以修复的。她和雷切尔都给了我很多她们认为可以奏效的歌曲建议，我可以在幻灯片期间播放，以获得正确的感受。这并不复杂。贝丝说基本上每个人都知道的任何歌都能胜任。流行歌曲、高能量歌曲，这些是最好的。
Rachel thinks it's all about the lyrics. "I hope you had the time of your life." "As we go on we remember all the times we had together."
雷切尔认为这全看歌词。“我希望你拥有生命中最美好的时光。”“当我们继续前进，我们记得我们在一起的所有时光。”
But then there are also the songs like "End of the Road," "Hard to Say Goodbye to Yesterday," or like that Sarah McLaughlin song, "I Will Remember You," whatever.
但还有像《End of the Road》、《Hard to Say Goodbye to Yesterday》或者萨拉·麦克拉克兰的那首《I Will Remember You》，诸如此类的歌。
I forgot about "End of the Road." "End of the Road," that's--
我忘了《End of the Road》了。《End of the Road》，那是——
Oh, yeah, "End of the Road."
哦，是的，《End of the Road》。
Yeah.
是的。
Where it's just, like, hitting the nail right on the head.
就像，直接点中要害。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
It's just like, let's have some big feelings about something ending.
就像是，让我们对某件事的结束产生一些强烈的情感。
Yeah, it's so on the nose.
是的，太直白了。
This is a particular kind of art form.
这是一种特殊的艺术形式。
Yeah.
是的。
And it doesn't call for much subtlety.
它不需要太多的微妙之处。
[MUSIC - "END OF THE ROAD" BY BOYZ II MEN]
[音乐 - Boyz II Men的《End of the Road》]
(SINGING) Although we've come to the end of the road, still--
（歌唱）尽管我们已经走到了路的尽头，仍然——
There is one song-- Bess and Rachel both mentioned it-- that was the perfect slideshow song in all the ways. It was poppy, everyone knew it, had the right energy, and the lyrics tell you exactly what to feel.
有一首歌——贝丝和雷切尔都提到了它——在各个方面都是完美的幻灯片歌曲。它朗朗上口，每个人都知道，有正确的能量，歌词告诉你准确的感受。
The R Kelly song, "The World's Greatest," which for a number of reasons, you can no longer really do. But it's a perfect, perfect slideshow song.
R·凯利的歌，《The World's Greatest》，出于一些原因，你已经不能再用它了。但它是完美的、完美的幻灯片歌曲。
That was in heavy rotation for many years.
那有很多年都在循环播放。
Right? Like, this man who did these terrible things and should not be the hero of any child happened to have written, like, two of the greatest slideshow songs ever. And I don't know why, but it hits me every time. Like, the idea-- like, I am a marching band, I'm a mountain. Something about that and seeing the faces of kids, "I believe I can fly, I believe I can touch the sky," that sense of just, like, each of us having this sort of bigness to us.
对吧？就像，这个做了这些可怕事情、不应该成为任何孩子英雄的人，恰好写了两首有史以来最伟大的幻灯片歌曲。我不知道为什么，但它每次都打动我。就像，那个想法——就像，我是一个行进乐队，我是一座山。关于那个想法，看到孩子们脸上的表情，“我相信我能飞，我相信我能触碰天空，”那种我们每个人都有某种宏大的感觉。
Obviously, I'm not going to play R Kelly under my second grader's slideshow. But all the other songs Bess and Rachel recommended, they all just feel too sentimental. And I don't feel sentimental about the last year. I don't think I want to feel sentimental about the last year of school. Like "End of the Road"-- I [BLEEP] wish it was the end of the road.
显然，我不会在二年级学生的幻灯片下播放R·凯利。但贝丝和雷切尔推荐的所有其他歌曲，它们都太感伤了。而我并不感伤过去的一年。我觉得我不想对最后一年学校生活感到感伤。就像《End of the Road》——我[消音]希望那真的是路的尽头。
But I did give it a try. I sat with the slideshow and tried to put music under it. Bess had suggested a Beatles song, and there is a Beatles song that I sing to my kid at bedtime. It's sappy, has all the right lyrics, but it didn't work. It's too much about him and me, not his class or his school. I did not believe this slideshow was salvageable.
但我确实尝试了一下。我坐在幻灯片前，尝试在下面放音乐。贝丝建议了一首披头士的歌，有一首披头士的歌我在睡前唱给我孩子听。它很感伤，有所有正确的歌词，但它没奏效。它更多是关于他和我的，不是他的班级或学校。我不相信这个幻灯片可以补救。
There was one other kind of slideshow song that Bess talked about, one she'd seen work recently at her mother-in-law's 90th birthday party. And it didn't work because it was a song everyone knew or because the lyrics tell you how to feel. She said it works because it makes you think of a particular place.
还有另一种幻灯片歌曲是贝丝谈到的，一种她在婆婆90岁生日派对上看到奏效的。它奏效不是因为它是每个人都知道的歌，也不是因为歌词告诉你感受如何。她说它奏效是因为它让你想起了特定的地方。
She comes from like, this little town, and it's like Un Bolero-- you know, like just a traditional like, small town ballad that was sung about the town that she was from.
她来自像，这种小镇，它就像Bolero（波莱罗）——你知道，就是一首关于她家乡的传统小镇民谣。
I started to think about that and what song I associate with this specific group of people and this specific place. There's really only one. Every year since my oldest was in pre-K-- so, seven years-- at the end of the year assembly, the kids sing a song called "This Pretty Planet." I've never loved the song, and I did not miss it when a new music teacher came in recently and retired it. But it did seem like it might work for this. And it did.
我开始思考那个，以及我将什么歌与这群特定的人和这个特定的地方联系起来。真的只有一个。从我老大上学前班开始——也就是七年——在学年末的集会上，孩子们都会唱一首叫《This Pretty Planet》的歌。我从来没喜欢过这首歌，最近当一位新音乐老师进来并把它淘汰时，我也没怀念它。但它似乎确实适合这个。它确实做到了。
[MUSIC - "THIS PRETTY PLANET" BY TOM CHAPIN]
[音乐 - 汤姆·查平的《This Pretty Planet》]
(SINGING) This pretty planet spinning through space, your garden, your harbor, your holy place.
（歌唱）这颗漂亮的星球旋转在太空中，你的花园，你的港湾，你神圣的地方。
I know. They do hand motions and everything. It actually felt like watching a slideshow I had never seen before. The masks and the heaviness of the year were still there, but my brain didn't focus on them. Instead, I saw a picture I had totally missed of my kid leading a group of friends in some sort of stomping game in the yard. I saw a girl who couldn't read last year standing at the board with the pointer stick reading to everyone.
我知道。他们做手势什么的。它实际上感觉就像在看一个我从未见过的幻灯片。口罩和这一年的沉重感仍然存在，但我的大脑没有关注它们。相反，我看到了一张我完全错过的照片，我的孩子在院子里带领一群朋友玩某种踩踏游戏。我看到了一个去年还不会读书的女孩站在黑板前，拿着教鞭给每个人读书。
Mostly, I just saw the incredible resilience of all the people in that classroom and marveled at the teachers smiling and leading and so skillfully masking all the fear and chaos of the entire school year, so they could create something that looks like school.
大多时候，我只是看到了那个教室里所有人不可思议的韧性，惊叹于老师们微笑着带领，如此巧妙地掩盖了整个学年的恐惧和混乱，让他们能创造出看起来像学校的东西。
(SINGING) The morning light.
（歌唱）晨光。
It's not easy being with kids all the time. It's tedious and boring and hard, even when there's not a global pandemic. But there are these flashes of bigness. The slideshow takes all those flashes and bottles them up, so that you can look back over the past year for a few minutes-- ideally, no more than six-- with the right song playing, and actually see all the things you missed.
一直和孩子们在一起并不容易。它是乏味的、无聊的和艰难的，即使没有全球大流行。但有这些闪光时刻。幻灯片把所有这些闪光时刻收集起来，装进瓶子里，这样你就可以回顾过去一年——理想情况下不超过六分钟——在播放正确的歌曲的情况下，真正看到你错过的所有事情。
Chana Joffe Walt is one of the producers of our show.
查娜·乔夫·沃尔特是我们节目的制作人之一。
Track Four, What's the Frequency, Kenneth? So, so much musical discovery happens when we're kids, like you really find the songs that form your tastes when you're young, for the most part, or at least that's what happened with me. This last story is about someone discovering music who is much older, a guy named Ken Eglin, who was actually living in a nursing home in Boston-- the Duplex Nursing Home, it was called. This was decades ago, by the way.
第四首，《What's the Frequency, Kenneth?》。所以，所以许多音乐发现发生在我们还是孩子的时候，就像你确实找到了形成你品味的歌，当你还年轻的时候，大部分情况是这样，或者至少那是发生在我身上的事。这最后一个故事是关于一个年长得多的人发现音乐的故事，一个叫肯·埃格林的家伙，他当时住在波士顿的一家养老院——叫Duplex Nursing Home。顺便说一句，那是几十年前的事了。
There were 45 residents in the facility, all men. My friend David Greenberger was the activities director there in the late '70s and early '80s.
机构里有45名住户，全是男性。我的朋友大卫·格林伯格在70年代末和80年代初担任那里的活动主管。
So I started the job the beginning of '79, and I'd met Ken probably immediately because he walked with a walker, and he would sit himself right by-- there was a desk for the activities director, and there was, like, a cabin with stuff in it. And it was in the corner of a room where they also would have lunch and stuff.
所以我79年初开始这份工作，可能很快就认识了肯，因为他用助行器走路，他会把自己安顿在——那里有个活动主管的桌子，还有个带东西的柜子。它在一个房间的角落，他们也会在那里吃午饭什么的。
So Ken was always seated right by it, because he's like, hey, you, what are you doing? So whoever was an outsider was like, I got to know what's going on out there. He never saw himself as a guy in a nursing home. He's like, if it weren't for my leg, you know, and these spells that I get. You know, so he--
所以肯总是坐在它旁边，因为他就像，嘿，你，你在做什么？所以任何外人都会像，我得知道那里发生了什么。他从没把自己看作养老院里的男人。他就像，如果不是我的腿，你知道，还有这些我得的病。你知道，所以他——
Pointing to his head, he got some sort of spells?
指着头，他得了某种病？
He would have seizures, so he had had some kind of brain surgery, and you could see the scar on his head from that, so that affected how he could walk along. And he just started talking to me.
他会癫痫发作，所以他做过某种脑部手术，你可以看到他头上的疤痕，所以那影响了他走路。他只是开始和我说话。
Ken was a talker. You wouldn't know it looking at him, but he had been a tap dancer in nightclubs back in the '30s, part of the jazz scene in Boston. He said he had met jazz icons like Billie Holiday, Charlie Parker, and Lester Young, who he called Prez.
肯是个话匣子。看着他你不会知道，但他曾在30年代的夜总会里当过踢踏舞者，是波士顿爵士乐圈的一员。他说他见过爵士乐偶像比如比莉·哈乐黛、查利·帕克和莱斯特·杨，他称他为“总统”。
During a saxophone solo, he would be the guy in the audience yelling go, go, go, go, go. Ken also drank a lot back in the day. According to his intake papers, the surgery he'd had was for subdural hematoma, a leaking blood vessel in his brain, probably from falling down the stairs one time when he was drunk.
在萨克斯独奏期间，他会是观众中大喊“走，走，走，走，走”的那个人。肯年轻时也喝很多酒。根据他的收录资料，他做过手术是因为硬膜下血肿，脑部血管渗漏，可能是一次喝醉后从楼梯上摔下来导致的。
He also had diabetes, semiparalysis on his left side, and he had no family to speak of. His siblings and parents had all died. And even given all of that, he was still this upbeat, smiley charmer. Said that if David didn't go ahead and marry his girlfriend, he was going to meet up with her on the corner with two bottles of John Jameson.
他还有糖尿病，左侧半身瘫痪，也没有家人可言。他的兄弟姐妹和父母都去世了。即便如此，他仍然是个乐观、爱笑、迷人的老头。说如果大卫不赶紧娶他的女朋友，他就要在拐角处带上两瓶约翰·詹姆森威士忌去见她。
David was a denizen of his own very different kind of music scene. He played in a band in the heyday of Boston rock, a skinny, arty, 25-year-old white guy with a mustache. Compared to Ken, who was Black, a World War II vet in his mid-60s, and for whom going to shows was well in the past. Still, music was something they easily bonded over.
大卫是他自己那种非常不同的音乐场景的居民。他在波士顿摇滚的全盛时期在一个乐队演奏，一个瘦削、艺术气息、25岁的白人小伙子留着胡子。比起肯，他是黑人，是二战老兵，60多岁，去看演出已是过去式。尽管如此，音乐是他们容易结缘的东西。
Ken wanted to hear music. And specifically, wanted to know what was I listening to? There was an element in him where he was like, what's going on out there? And he'd point out the window. I got to know what's going on out there. And first, I just played him some stuff, and I think the first thing I played him was The Shaggs.
肯想听音乐。特别想知道我听的是什么？他身上有个元素就像，外面正在发生什么？他会指着窗外。我得知道外面发生了什么。起初，我只是给他放了一些东西，我想我放的第一样东西是The Shaggs。
Sort of the outsider art trio of sisters from New Hampshire. They sounded like this.
有点像来自新罕布什尔州的姐妹局外艺术三人组。它们听起来像这样。
[MUSIC - THE SHAGGS]
[音乐 - The Shaggs]
(SINGING) All the rich people want what the poor people's got. And the poor people want what the rich people's got.
（歌唱）所有有钱人都想要穷人有的。而穷人都想要有钱人有的。
Ken had a lot to say about The Shaggs. We actually know exactly what his reaction was because David wrote it down, this whole rapid-fire soliloquy. David read it to me.
肯对The Shaggs有很多话要说。我们实际上确切知道他的反应，因为大卫把它写了下来，这整段连珠炮式的独白。大卫念给我听。
I couldn't dance to that, not regular dancing with a woman. I could soft shoe with that. Any of this music you're playing for me, I could soft shoe with or buck and wing with it, or off-time with it. Personally myself, I could do it. I don't know if everybody else could. I know for a fact that Gene Kelly and Fred Astaire could dance to that. And if they could, I damn sure could do it myself. And I pray to God someday you can see me dance to that, that I'm well enough to do it. Let me tell you something, Dave, any time anybody--
那样的我跳不了，不是跟女人跳的那种正规舞。我能随着那个跳软底鞋舞。你给我放的任何这类音乐，我都能跳软底鞋舞或者巴克舞，或者跳着跳着脱节。就我自己而言，我能做到。不知道别人能不能。我知道事实是金·凯利和弗雷德·阿斯泰尔能跟着跳。如果他们能，我肯定也能自己做到。我向上帝祈祷总有一天你能看我随着那个跳舞，我身体够好的话。让我告诉你一件事，戴夫，任何时候任何人——
I just need to pause here for a second and talk about the reason David wrote down what Ken had to say about The Shaggs. Early on in his job at the nursing home, David started a small magazine, a zine, called The Duplex Planet. It was mainly quotes from the residents and snippets of their conversations that he thought were surprising, or funny, or poignant.
我只需要在这里暂停一下，谈谈大卫写下肯对The Shaggs的看法的原因。在他养老院工作的初期，大卫开始了一本小杂志，叫《Duplex Planet》。它主要是住户的引语和他们谈话的片段，他觉得那些内容令人惊讶、有趣或辛酸。
It was self-published, hundreds of subscribers, not thousands, but it had this devoted following. It lasted decades after David left the nursing home. He interviewed old folks all over the country. There was a comic book version, live performances, CDs, everything. And Ken Eglin was one of the early standout regulars that readers look forward to hearing from every month.
它是自费出版的，有数百名订户，不是成千上万，但它有这种忠实的追随者。它在大卫离开养老院后持续了几十年。他采访了全国各地的老人。有漫画书版本、现场表演、CD，应有尽有。肯·埃格林是早期杰出的常客，读者每个月都期待听到他的声音。
David created a special section for him, actually, a music review column called "Ken's Corner." He'd play Ken songs on a cassette Walkman, Ken would say what he thought of them, and David would sit and take notes. In the first official Ken's Corner column, Issue 29, he reviewed "Money Won't Buy You Happiness" by The Incredible Casuals.
大卫甚至为他专门开辟了一个板块，一个叫“肯的角落”的乐评专栏。他会在卡式随身听上给肯放歌，肯会说出他的想法，大卫会坐下来做笔记。在第一个正式的“肯的角落”专栏，第29期，他评价了不可思议休闲乐队的《Money Won't Buy You Happiness》。
He says it's crazy, it's really groovy-- or as you say today, it's really nice. And I say--
他说这很疯狂，真的很棒——或者正如你们今天说的，这真的很“nice”。我说——
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Cracks me up. As you say today, "nice." As if we'd gotten rid of the word "crazy." It's like he was used to beatnik talk. You guys don't do that anymore, right? But I say, it's slang, it's groovy. It had a beat, and the beat was beautiful. I like it. I like what I hear. Give them a chance. They'll be up there. These kids can go up. They can go. There's no stopping them now. If they stop, I'll tell them they're fools. There's that old saying now, you probably never heard it. Peg Leg Bates, he said, don't stop right there. Keep going.
逗死我了。正如你们今天说的，“nice”。好像我们已经摆脱了“疯狂”这个词。他就像习惯了垮掉的一代的话语。你们这些家伙不再那样说话了，对吧？但我说，这是俚语，这是时髦的。它有节奏，节奏很美。我喜欢。我喜欢我听到的。给他们一个机会。他们会出人头地的。这些孩子能行。他们能走下去。现在没什么能阻止他们。如果他们停下来，我会告诉他们他们是傻瓜。现在有句老话，你可能从没听过。佩格·莱格·贝茨说，别停在那儿。继续走。
[MUSIC - "MONEY WON'T BUY YOU HAPPINESS" BY THE INCREDIBLE CASUALS]
[音乐 - 不可思议休闲乐队的《Money Won't Buy You Happiness》]
(SINGING) --don't force that. Money won't buy you happiness.
（歌唱）——别强求那个。金钱买不来幸福。
A lot of the reviews are like that, in a good way. There's this poetic repetition to his gushiness. And he's so encouraging. He'll be like, "those kids are going places," whether he's talking about The Incredible Casuals or a much more famous band, like The Clash.
很多评论都是这样的，以一种好的方式。他的热情中有一种诗意的重复。他如此令人振奋。他会像，“那些孩子会有一番作为的”，不管他是在谈论不可思议休闲乐队还是像冲击乐队这样更著名的乐队。
Quote, "Should I go, huh? No, no, don't go. Stay there, baby. These boys are all right. They're going to swing." Sometimes David would play an artist Ken had heard before, like Frank Sinatra or Elvis Presley. But mostly, it was stuff that was all new to him. And like those first-time-listening reaction videos that are on YouTube and TikTok now, it helped if you already knew the song he was talking about, because it allowed you to hear it through new ears, Ken's ears.
引用，“我应该走吗，嗯？不，不，别走。待在那儿，宝贝。这些男孩都很棒。他们会摇滚起来的。”有时大卫会给肯放他以前听过的艺术家，比如弗兰克·辛纳屈或埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。但大多时候，这对他来说都是全新的东西。就像YouTube和TikTok上现在有的那些“第一次听”的反应视频，如果你已经知道了他在谈论的那首歌，那会有帮助，因为它允许你通过新的耳朵，肯的耳朵来听。
There was a complete lack of knowledge of context. He doesn't know anything about the history of the person, which can be freeing. He's just like, whoa, this thing's just rolling over me. It's really about how you would talk with a friend while you're listening to music.
对语境完全缺乏了解。他不知道关于这个人历史的任何东西，那可以是解放的。他只是像，哇，这东西正席卷着我。这实际上是关于当你听音乐时你会如何与朋友交谈。
He was my friend. It was never in a ironic way. I don't even like that whole thing that gets done sometimes like, let's see what Grandpa says about Kiss, or the Slits, or whatever, just some thing that you normally wouldn't be playing for Grandpa.
他是我朋友。这从来不是讽刺的方式。我甚至不喜欢有时候那种被做的事情，比如，让我们看看爷爷对KISS乐队，或者Slits乐队，或者任何什么东西怎么说，只是你通常不会给爷爷放的东西。
Out of the mouths of babes, except for it's not babes, it's old people.
出自婴儿之口，除了这不是婴儿，是老年人。
Yeah, the reverse babe, whatever.
是的，反转的婴儿，管他呢。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
But a lot of times, he would relate himself to it. I mean, basically all these things, while they are music reviews, the whole thing together is a portrait of Ken, described in these funny little ways, like piecing together a puzzle, or the little bits of it are all coming together.
但很多时候，他会把自己与之联系起来。我是说，基本上所有这些东西，虽然它们是乐评，但整体拼凑起来是肯的画像，以这些有趣的小方式描述出来，就像拼凑拼图，或者它的小片段都聚集在一起。
That's what it really is.
那才真是它。
Yeah.
是的。
Not just a portrait of his personality, which is palpable, but practically Ken's whole life is depicted in the reviews. Reacting to "The Lord's Prayer" by the Beach Boys, he said, "I was a Methodist, and then when they sent me to school they switched me around and made me a Catholic. That was the Matron. She didn't like me because I was too popular and too good a dancer, but I didn't care."
不仅仅是他个性的画像，那触手可及，而且几乎肯的一生都在评论中被描绘出来了。在回应海滩男孩的《The Lord's Prayer》时，他说，“我曾经是卫理公会教徒，然后当他们送我去学校时，他们把我换了过来，让我成了天主教徒。那是嬷嬷。她不喜欢我，因为我太受欢迎，舞跳得太好，但我不在乎。”
Ken was a rebel, crashing parties, no matter what floor they were on. He talks about climbing the sides of houses to get in. The words "raising hell" appear at least a couple of times. But there were more placid memories too. He's down at the Charles River in a couple of the reviews, sleeping on a blanket. Or he's at Magazine Beach, where he used to be a lifeguard. This is from when he listened to Captain Beefheart's "Tropical Hot Dog Night."
肯是个叛逆者，不管他们在几楼，总是去闯派对。他谈到爬上房子的侧面进去。词语“大闹一场”至少出现了好几次。但也还有更平静的记忆。他在评论中提到了查尔斯河几次，躺在毯子上睡觉。或者他在杂志海滩，那里他曾经是救生员。这是他在听牛肉心船长的《Tropical Hot Dog Night》时说的。
"I'm sitting there, laying on my blanket, and I got the beat in my body and my blood. And I look over to one side of me, and there's a blonde girl with long hair way down her back, and she's got those tight bikinis on and shaking it up. She's tearing up the world. And you got to get up and get the same beat that she's got. And there you are--"
“我坐在那儿，躺在我的毯子上，我的身体和血液里都有节奏。我看向我的一边，有个金发长发及腰的女孩，穿着那件紧身比基尼在摇摆。她正在把世界搅得天翻地覆。你必须站起来，获得和她一样的节奏。然后你就到了那儿——”
Apparently, there were a lot of women in Ken's life. He never married. Seems like he rejected all of that. But he had girlfriends, and not always happily. "It Was an Accident" by NRBQ got him talking about the time one woman told him she was pregnant with his baby, and he skipped town. Turned out it wasn't his.
显然，肯的生活中有很多女人。他从未结婚。看起来他拒绝了这一切。但他有过女朋友，而且并不总是幸福的。NRBQ的《It Was an Accident》让他谈到了一个女人告诉他她怀了他的孩子的那次，他跳过城逃走了。结果证明那不是他的。
And sometimes all of the carousing and carrying on intersects with America's troubled history. This is what he said in response to Bunky and Jake's, "If I Had A Dream." "If we played music like that back in the '30s, the police, the Irish cops, would raise hell with us. Now what I'm trying to tell you, segregation was a bitch. They couldn't stand me dancing with the white girls.
有时所有的狂欢和闹腾与美国动荡的历史交织在一起。这是他在回应Bunky and Jake的《If I Had A Dream》时所说的。“如果我们30年代那样播放音乐，警察，那些爱尔兰警察，会跟我们大闹一场。现在我想告诉你的是，种族隔离是个混蛋。他们无法忍受我和白人女孩跳舞。
We'd be doing the Lindy Hop in Boston Common, going wild, smoking reefers-- we called them reefers back then. Now they call it marijuana. We'd be dancing, and along comes a pounder, which is a cop, and he says all right now, break it up. Sometimes you run into a cop saying, hey, that's my cousin you're dancing with, boy."
我们在波士顿公园跳林迪舞，疯狂跳着，抽大麻——我们那时叫大麻。现在他们叫大麻。我们正在跳舞，过来一个警察，他说是时候了，打散它。有时你会遇到一个警察说，嘿，那是我表亲，你正在和她跳舞，小子。”
[MUSIC - "IF I HAD A DREAM" BY BUNKY AND JAKE]
[音乐 - Bunky and Jake的《If I Had A Dream》]
(SINGING) Don't ask me what do I mean if I had a dream.
（歌唱）别问我如果我有一个梦是什么意思。
To be clear, Ken did not like everything David played him. Some of the reviews begin with "it was weird," or "I don't buy that." "Cat Food" by King Crimson was a hard no. And then this one review was such an intricate, multilayered, yet subtly murderous pan.
需要明确的是，肯并不是喜欢大卫给他放的所有东西。有些评论以“那很奇怪”或“我不买账”开头。King Crimson的《Cat Food》是彻底的拒绝。然后这一个评论是一段如此错综复杂、多层次，又带有隐晦杀伤力的抨击。
Oh, here.
哦，这里。
David had to read it to me.
大卫不得不念给我听。
"This Diamond Ring" by Gary Lewis and the Playboys. "That I wouldn't buy, but it sounds all right. Some more horns in there would have helped a little bit, and change the tempo a little too. A better singer too, who could have come more clear with it. A lot of those words I couldn't get. You could change the lyrics in there too. He was corn. He had a tempo in there, but I just couldn't get it. They got to switch it around. I don't mean all the way around, just halfway."
加里·刘易斯和花花公子组合的《This Diamond Ring》。“那个我不会买，但它听起来还行。如果里面有更多的号角会更好一点，节奏也变一下。更好的歌手也会更好，能唱得更清楚。那很多歌词我听不懂。你也可以改变那里的歌词。他是玉米。他里面有节奏，但我就是抓不住它。他们得换一下。我不意味着全部换掉，只是换一半。”
So basically, he's now asked about adding horns, changing the lyrics, the tempo, and getting a different singer, but it's not totally bad. I mean, he's basically trying to be-- I don't want to hurt anybody's feelings, you know.
所以基本上，他现在要求增加号角，改变歌词，改变节奏，找一个不同的歌手，但这并不完全坏。我是说，他基本上在努力成为——我不想伤害任何人的感情，你知道。
[MUSIC - "THIS DIAMOND RING" BY GARY LEWIS]
[音乐 - 加里·刘易斯的《This Diamond Ring》]
I should also say, everyone at the nursing home knew about the zine. The owner told David he was really proud of what he was doing, and David showed Ken the Ken's Corner column in The Duplex Planet, but Ken was completely uninterested. He was like, why do I need a souvenir of myself talking?
我还应该说，养老院里的每个人都知道那本杂志。老板告诉大卫他真的很为他正在做的事情感到骄傲，大卫给肯看了《Duplex Planet》里的“肯的角落”专栏，但肯完全不感兴趣。他就像，我为什么需要一张我自己说话的纪念品？
Did he know how many people were reading these?
他知道有多少人在读这些东西吗？
I don't know if it really registered. I would tell him stuff, but it's such an abstract thing. All that mattered to him was he liked what we did.
我不知道它是否真的被注意到了。我会告诉他一些事，但这太抽象了。对他来说重要的是他喜欢我们做的。
Meanwhile, Ken's following swelled well beyond the readership of The Duplex Planet. Other publications started picking up the column. A rock sheet in Boston called The Noise, two alternative papers out of the Northwest. Rounder Records had David submit some of Ken's reviews for their mail order catalog.
与此同时，肯的追随者膨胀到远远超出了《Duplex Planet》的读者群。其他出版物开始转载这个专栏。波士顿的一份摇滚报纸叫《The Noise》，两份来自西北地区的另类报纸。Rounder Records让大卫为他们的邮购目录提交肯的一些评论。
Granted, David had a lot of music world connections from playing in his band, but he wasn't pushing for any of this exposure. And when Ken got to meet some of the musicians he reviewed, weirdly, it was Ken who was the celebrity in those interactions.
诚然，大卫在乐队演奏时有许多音乐界的关系，但他并没有推动任何这种曝光。当肯能见到他评价的一些音乐家时，奇怪的是，肯才是那些互动中的名人。
The Del Fuegos got in touch asking if Ken could produce them. A local Boston band called Pastiche dedicated a song to him, which he later reviewed. He and David appeared on a local TV show in Rhode Island together. David even read a couple of Ken's reviews on Late Night with Conan O'Brien. Whereas Ken had always said he wanted to know what was going on out in the world, now Ken was what was going on out in the world.
Del Fuegos联系大卫问肯是否能为他们制作。波士顿当地的一个乐队叫Pastiche把一首歌献给他，他后来评论了那首歌。他和大卫一起出现在罗德岛的一个当地电视节目上。大卫甚至在柯南·奥布莱恩的《深夜秀》上念了几篇肯的评论。而肯总是说他想知道外面的世界发生了什么，现在肯就是外面世界正在发生的事情。
Chandler Travis of The Incredible Casuals told me he liked Ken because Ken talked like a musician. David brought Ken to one of their shows. And The Casuals played at David's wedding party, where Ken was a guest. There's a Super 8 film with just a snippet of Ken at the party on it. He's wearing a gray suit jacket and a white shirt with a wide collar, no tie.
不可思议休闲乐队的钱德勒·特拉维斯告诉我他喜欢肯，因为肯说话像个音乐家。大卫带肯去参加了他们的演出。休闲乐队在大卫的婚礼派对上演奏，肯是客座嘉宾。有一个超级8电影上面有一小段肯在派对上的片段。他穿着灰色西装外套和白衬衫，大领子，没打领带。
You can't hear what Ken's saying over the crowd noise, but he's joking around, gesticulating. People lean in and laugh. He's a hit, and he knows it. "I had a ball that night," he said, in his review of The Easy Beats "Friday On My Mind." "Then I had to come back here and who's waiting for me at the front door but the gorilla. And that wine hit me when I got out of the car."
你在人群噪声中听不到肯在说什么，但他开玩笑，打着手势。人们凑过去大笑。他很受欢迎，而且他知道。“那天晚上我玩得很开心，”他在评价Easy Beats的《Friday On My Mind》时说。“然后我不得不回到这儿，在前门等我的是大猩猩。当我下车时，那葡萄酒击中了我。”
Another result of Ken's widening popularity, other people wanted in on the action. Started sending their own mixtapes for Ken to listen to. Cassettes. David still has them. All the songs are listed on the J-card or typed onto these little sheets of paper and folded up and shoved into the jewel case. One of the lists has a little note on it that says, "Dave, is it OK to put your own thing on here? If not, skip over it." And this tape was from the guitarist Glenn Jones. It's got Jelly Roll Morton on it and Elvis Presley and this tune.
肯声望扩大带来的另一个结果是，其他人也想参与进来。开始寄他们自己的混音带给肯听。卡带。大卫还有它们。所有的歌都列在J卡上或打字在这些小纸条上，折叠起来塞进珠宝盒。其中一个列表上有一个小笔记写着，“戴夫，把你自己的东西放在这里可以吗？如果不可以，跳过它。”这盘磁带来自吉他手格伦·琼斯。上面有杰利·罗尔·莫顿和埃尔维斯·普雷斯利，还有这首曲子。
[MUSIC - "STRANGER" BY LEFTY FRIZZELL]
[音乐 - Lefty Frizzell的《Stranger》]
(SINGING) Stranger, you're no stranger to me.
（歌唱）陌生人，你对我来说并不陌生。
"Stranger" by Lefty Frizzell. "I was crying a little bit during it. Man, that's a Western song if there ever was. That is one. 'No Stranger To Me.' Oh, man. That's what the cat said. Oh, man, take me back, take me right back to the Arizona desert. That kind of music gets you. So help me, it does. You've got the moon, and a sucker singing like this, and girls walking around in little slips that you can see right through.
Lefty Frizzell的《Stranger》。“我在听的时候哭了一点。老兄，那是一首西部歌曲，如果说真的有的话。那是一首。‘对我来说并不陌生。’哦，老兄。那就是那个家伙说的。哦，老兄，带我回去，把我带回亚利桑那沙漠。那种音乐抓住你了。帮帮我，它真的抓住了。你有月亮，有个傻瓜像这样唱着，还有女孩们走来走去，穿着你能一眼看穿的小内衣。”
It's music that's like this that takes you, their voices so plain, that you can understand what they're saying. To me, I know what they're singing. There's lyrics in there you may not know, but you will put them in there yourself. I've done that so many times, just sat there and listened to bands play and put the words in myself, the way I hear them. It's easy to do if you got the music in your body. Man, you're going to do it. That's from the heart."
“像这样的音乐，它抓住你，他们的嗓音如此平淡，你能理解他们正在说的。对我来说，我知道他们唱的是什么。里面有你可能不知道的歌词，但你会自己把它们放进去。我已经做了很多次了，只是坐在那儿听乐队演奏，自己把歌词放进去，就像我听到的那样。如果你身体里有音乐，这很容易做到。老兄，你会做到的。那是发自肺腑的。”
(SINGING) Stranger, you're no stranger to me.
（歌唱）陌生人，你对我来说并不陌生。
In all, Ken dictated 692 music reviews, give or take, over just a couple of years. And then his health got worse. He developed cancer. He was transferred from The Duplex Nursing Home to a local VA Hospital. David kept visiting him, encouraged other people, Ken's fans, to do the same.
总共，肯在短短几年内听写了692个乐评，大概。然后他的健康恶化了。他得了癌症。他从Duplex Nursing Home被转到了当地的退伍军人医院。大卫一直去看他，鼓励其他人，肯的粉丝们，做同样的事。
He was at the VA. It was clear he's going to be there for a while. He was-- maybe he knew he was never going to leave there. Maybe he knew he was getting worse. He certainly wasn't going back to the nursing home. And so, it was really just a request. He asked me, he said, those reviews, could you bring them in here for me?
他在退伍军人医院。很清楚他将在那里待上一段时间。他——也许他知道他永远不会离开那里。也许他知道他在恶化。他肯定不会回到养老院了。所以，那真的只是一个请求。他问我，他说，那些评论，你能带到这里来给我吗？
Not all of them or anything, but just a selection of them to have.
不是全部或什么的，只是其中的一部分。
He wanted them in a folder by his bed at the VA hospital because I think, well, he knew, I'm an old guy that's just being moved around. And so he would tell people, that's me. You know, the nurses and stuff at the VA hospital. He wanted some identity outside of just being a frail guy whose body's breaking down.
他想要它们在他退伍军人医院的床头文件夹里，因为我想，好吧，他知道，我是一个被移来移去的老头。所以他会告诉人们，那就是我。你知道，退伍军人医院的护士什么的。他想要除了作为一个身体正在崩溃的虚弱老人之外的身份。
At the nursing home, he was Ken. He had a level of respect. But at the VA hospital, he wouldn't have had any of that. It was like, you know, you'd get moved into the hallway. Now we got to do this for him. We're sending you down to this room for whatever tests. And especially for somebody who doesn't really have family or an advocate.
在养老院，他是肯。他有一定程度的尊重。但在退伍军人医院，他不会有这些。它就像，你知道，你会搬到走廊里。现在我们要为你做这个。我们送你去这个房间进行任何检查。特别是对于一个没有真正家人或拥护者的人来说。
They were in touch with me, I got my name onto his chart. And I remember I got a call late at night. maybe it was 2:00 in the morning or something. And just, it was just, you know, just wanted to call and let you know that Ken died tonight.
他们与我保持联系，我把我的名字放在了他的图表上。我记得我深夜接到一个电话，可能是凌晨2点什么的。而且只是，只是，你知道，只是想打电话告诉你，肯今晚去世了。
It was January 29, 1984. Ken was 68. A featured obituary ran in the Boston Sunday Globe, headlined "Kenneth Eglin, rock music critic, began as tap dancer in '30s." It didn't mention his seizures, or his diabetes, or that he used a walker toward the end of his life. It did quote from one of his reviews. "No matter what instrument you're playing," said one of the quotes, "You can't lose that first beat, or you're through."
那是1984年1月29日。肯68岁。《波士顿星期日环球报》刊登了一篇专题讣告，标题为“肯尼斯·埃格林，摇滚乐评人，从30年代的踢踏舞者开始”。它没有提到他的癫痫，或他的糖尿病，或者他生命最后阶段使用助行器。它确实引用了他评论中的一段话。“无论你在演奏什么乐器，”引语中的一段说，“你不能丢掉第一拍，否则你就完了。”
David, at the time, was 29. He'd only been to one or two funerals at that point, other guys from the nursing home. He'd certainly never had to organize one before, but it was David who called the funeral home to work out the details of the wake. Fans of Ken cycled in and out, paying their respects, some who had met him in the past and others who hadn't.
大卫当时29岁。那时候他只参加过一两次葬礼，是养老院的其他家伙。他肯定从没组织过一次，但大卫打电话给殡仪馆处理守灵细节。肯的粉丝们络绎不绝，表达敬意，有些是在过去见过他的人，有些则没有。
David arranged for some of Ken's favorite music to be played-- Sun Ra, the Beach Boys, Jonathan Richman. And he took care of this one other detail that felt important.
大卫安排播放了一些肯最喜欢的音乐——太阳拉，海滩男孩，乔纳森·里奇曼。他处理了这个感觉很重要的一个细节。
I gave them the tape, the last mixtape that Ken never got to hear. Came too late. There just wasn't a time. You know, his condition was deteriorating. I would go and see him, but I wasn't trying to get headphones on him and have him listen to stuff. So I then gave it to the funeral director, and I had him put it in the pocket of his jacket. So he was buried with it. He's buried with the tape. So I don't remember-- know what was on it.
我给了他们录音带，肯永远没能听到的最后一张混音带。来得太晚了。只是没有时间。你知道，他的病情在恶化。我会去看他，但我没试图给他戴上耳机让他听东西。所以我后来给了殡仪员，我让他把它放在他夹克的口袋里。所以他带着它下葬了。他带着那盘磁带下葬了。所以我记得——不知道里面有什么。
You don't remember any of the songs?
你不记得任何歌了吗？
No. That was meant to be a thing that I would have done with him. It was for him to hear, and that wasn't possible. So--
不。那本意应该是我会和他一起做的事情。它是让他听的，那是不可能的。所以——
It's like it belongs to him in a way.
它就像在某种程度上属于他。
Yeah. What am I supposed to do with this?
是的。我该怎么处理这个？
There's this thing that happens when two friends sit and listen to music together a lot. It happened with my friend Paul and me when we were kids and he turned me onto some of the music I still listen to. And it happened with Ken and David. Even when you go your separate ways, in whatever way that happens, it's like you take that person with you. You're forever informed by that friendship. Certain songs will always remind you of that person, even when they become associated with other people in your life.
当两个朋友坐在一起经常听音乐时会发生这种事。当我和我朋友保罗还是孩子时发生了，他把我转向了我至今仍在听的一些音乐。而在肯和大卫身上也发生了。即使当你各奔东西，以任何方式发生，那就像你带着那个人一起走。你永远被那份友谊所通知。某些歌总会让你想起那个人，即使他们与你生活中的其他人联系起来。
And when you hear those songs, you think about other aspects of that friendship, of that person, that you really loved. Stuff that maybe didn't occur to you as much back when you were hanging out with them. I asked David what Ken's last review was. He said he wasn't sure because he'd collect so many at once, and then mete them out in batches as he published the magazine. But this is the last one in the last Ken's Corner column in Issue 55. That's a song by Ted Hawkins.
当你听到那些歌时，你想到那份友谊的其他方面，那个你真的很爱的人。你年轻时和他们在一起时可能没那么想到的东西。我问大卫肯的最后一个评论是什么。他说他不确定，因为他一次收集太多，然后在杂志出版时分批发布。但这最后一个是在最后一期“肯的角落”专栏，第55期。那是泰德·霍金斯的一首歌。
His song "TWA." He couldn't get the name of it. I told him it was "TWA." He nodded and he said, well, "happiness" was in there, anyway. I know "happiness" was in there. All right. I liked it.
他的歌《TWA》。他不知道名字。我告诉他是《TWA》。他点点头说，嗯，“幸福”在里面，无论如何。我知道“幸福”在里面。好吧。我喜欢它。
[MUSIC - "TWA" BY TED HAWKINS]
[音乐 - 泰德·霍金斯的《TWA》]
(SINGING) --laid out in the sky. Special steps were taken to please you, so you know they cares about you. Expert--
（歌唱）——铺开在天空中。特别采取了措施来取悦你，所以你知道他们在乎你。专家——
If you want to know more about David and his work, you can go to DavidGreenberger.com. and Berger is B-E-R-G-E-R. There's also a documentary film about him in progress called "Beyond The Duplex Planet."
如果你想了解更多关于大卫和他的工作，你可以去DavidGreenberger.com。Berger是B-E-R-G-E-R。还有一部关于他的正在制作中的纪录片，叫《Beyond The Duplex Planet》。
Your true happiness means their success. Your true happiness means their success.
你真正的幸福意味着他们的成功。你真正的幸福意味着他们的成功。
Track Five, I Talk In Tunes. So I was sitting with Chandler Travis of The Incredible Casuals, who I mentioned in that story. And he was just sort of thinking out loud at one point and knew what I was working on. And he's like, I wonder if you guys might need a song, like a mixtape song for the end of that show that you're doing.
第五首，《I Talk In Tunes》。所以我正和我在故事中提到的不可思议休闲乐队的钱德勒·特拉维斯坐在一起。他正大声思考，知道我正在做什么。他说，我想知道你们是否可能需要一首歌，像一首你们正在做的那节目的混音带歌曲。
And I was like, yeah, why? You got one? And he's like, no, but I could write one. It's actually where the title of the episode comes from. Enjoy.
我说，是的，为什么？你有一首吗？他说，没有，但我可以写一首。它实际上是剧集标题的来源。请欣赏。
[MUSIC - "THIS IS JUST SOME SONGS" BY CHANDLER TRAVIS]
[音乐 - 钱德勒·特拉维斯的《This Is Just Some Songs》]
(SINGING) This is just some songs. I hope you like songs. In a way, to me, they're medicine. It's stupid that pop that made my IQ drop, I can't get them out of the head they're in.
（歌唱）这只是一些歌。我希望你喜欢歌。在某种意义上，对我来说，它们是药。让我的智商下降的流行音乐很蠢，我无法把它们赶出脑子。
This is just some songs. You probably hate songs, but I wanna know who I'm talking to. And if you understand the sounds we make, you leave the ground. And fine, if you don't, well, never mind. Checking in, nothing ventured, calling out, just stuff.
这只是一些歌。你可能讨厌歌，但我想要知道我在和谁说话。如果你理解我们发出的声音，你就会离开地面。好吧，如果你不理解，那就算了。报个道，没什么好冒险的，叫出来，只是一些东西。
I know you don't know me, and I don't really know you. Maybe we should not get married yet. But first, you need to hear the stuff I got to give you to show you where the treasure's buried at. No big deal, a couple things to listen to, tell you how deep inside I am. Maybe you can tell me why, when I try to communicate, you probably see another fancy dan.
我知道你不了解我，我也不真正了解你。也许我们现在不该结婚。但首先，你需要听听我得给你的东西，告诉你宝藏埋在哪儿。没什么大不了，几样东西去听，告诉你我心里有多深。也许你可以告诉我为什么，当我试图沟通时，你可能看到另一个花花公子。
I wanna know who I'm talking to. And I talk in twos. I talk in twos. I talk in twos. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. I made you a mixtape.
我想要知道我在和谁说话。我用双调谈话。我用双调谈话。我用双调谈话。喔喔。喔喔。我为你制作了一张混音带。
Today's program was produced by Nadia Reiman and myself. The people who put our show together include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Zoe Chace, Chana Joffe Walt, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Ari Saperstein, Laura Starcheski, Lilly Sullivan, Matt Tierney, and Chloe Weiner.
今天的节目由娜迪亚·雷曼和我制作。把我们节目放在一起的人包括Bim Adewunmi、Elna Baker、Susan Burton、Ben Calhoun、Dana Chivvis、Zoe Chace、Chana Joffe Walt、Seth Lind、Tobin Low、Miki Meek、Lina Misitzis、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Ari Saperstein、Laura Starcheski、Lilly Sullivan、Matt Tierney和Chloe Weiner。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Fact checking by Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Rudy Lee, and Christopher Swetala. Rikki Bates played drums and was the mix engineer on "I Talk In Tunes."
我们的管理编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。事实核查由Andrea Lopez Cruzado、Rudy Lee和Christopher Swetala进行。Rikki Bates打鼓，是《I Talk In Tunes》的混音工程师。
Special thanks to Kelefa Sanneh, Hanif Abdurraqib, Neil Drumming, Mallory Zuckerman, Geoff Muldaur, Georgia Webber, Dan Brier, Beth Harrington, and The Josh Craig. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks also and always to our boss, Ira Glass. He got drunk on the set of Wheel of Fortune, passed out, and when he woke up, he saw Vanna White smiling and the completed puzzle. He was so confused.
特别感谢Kelefa Sanneh、Hanif Abdurraqib、Neil Drumming、Mallory Zuckerman、Geoff Muldaur、Georgia Webber、Dan Brier、Beth Harrington和The Josh Craig。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》通过PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。也总是感谢我们的老板，艾拉·格拉斯。他在《财富之轮》片场喝醉了，晕倒了，当他醒来时，他看到凡娜·怀特在微笑和完成拼图。他很困惑。
Did I-- did I tell her that it spelled that?
我有没有——我有告诉过她那上面拼出了什么吗？
I'm Sean Cole. Join us next week for more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔。下周加入我们，收听更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "I TALK IN TUNES"]
[音乐 - 《I Talk In Tunes》]
(SINGING) I talk in tunes. I talk in tunes.
（歌唱）我用双调谈话。我用双调谈话。
Next week on the podcast of This American Life, one of our producers, Parker, grew up in Baltimore like I did. And she explained to me that she and other Black kids of her generation were terrified going to this history museum called The Great Blacks in Wax.
下周在《美国生活》的播客上，我们的一位制作人帕克，像我一样在巴尔的摩长大。她向我解释说，她和她那一代的其他黑人孩子在去这个叫“伟大的蜡像黑人”历史博物馆时很害怕。
This week, Parker goes back.
这周，帕克回去了。
I'm sorry. I just got distracted by them trying to shove the guy in the oven. Sorry. What?
抱歉。我只是被他们试图把那个家伙塞进烤箱弄得心烦意乱。抱歉。什么？
What?
什么？
No, that's the Underground Railroad. That's a fake oven.
不，那是地下铁路。那是一个假烤箱。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
What's Suitable for Children? Next week on the podcast or on your local public radio station.
什么适合孩子？下周在播客或在你的当地公共广播电台收听。